I feel like you don't really drink
coffee that much oh brother I am
converted really oh yeah man I've been
sipping and why is that because the
coffee's really good in Europe yeah I
mean it's just [__] dude you're you just
you know you makes you I don't know just
makes you want to drink coffee smoke
cigarettes kiss a dude on the lips yeah
yeah now you're talking it's just all A
vibe out here
grab a little coffee to go you're like
why eat I could look like a rock star
smoke cigarettes see some other skinny
guy walking down the street you're like
you're my white pants no boxers mate how
are you how are you on your way to the
tube are you
me too